my great-grandfather came over to
America from northern Iran around the
turn of the 20th century escaping the
massacres there was a moment where he
was cornered by some men that demanded
that he deny his faith or they would
shoot him but he refused he said he'd
rather die than deny his faith in Christ
and so they pulled the trigger but the
gun didn't go off my dad came from Hong
Kong in the 60s I think the biggest
thing that I don't have to face that my
dad had to face was probably just
financial he started off just doing
restaurant work he was slowly able to
get a job as an engineer my grandmother
emigrated from Cuba to the States in
1967 via the freedom flights when Castro
came in they had to leave everything
behind the moment you made it known to
the government that you were planning on
leaving via the Freedom flights they had
someone watching you every day day in
and day out so they basically boarded
the flight with just the clothing on
their back and I think my mom had a doll
my grandmother emigrated from Mexico in
the 50s my grandfather came to America
to make money and send it back to the
family she decided enough was enough and
the family needed to be together so she
sold all of their earthly possessions
and sent him a telegram saying we will
be arriving and just left the thumb my
mom came from Ghana to America in 1979
her father died when she was 1 and her
mother died when she was about 10 years
old my mother is someone who's very
thoughtful and she thinks of everyone
and I think that's always something that
I've appreciated and I've always hoped
that sometime in the future I'd be able
to become like that I am excited Oh
looks amazing it's kind of a way to like
like literally stepping into his shoes
kind of a thing it's funny because
growing up people said that I kind of
looked like him but now I look a lot
like him I totally I told my dad these
glasses they really helped it I think if
if we ever needed proof that I'm my
dad's child then this is it it can take
second generation kids a little bit more
time than other kids to develop that
feeling of self-worth oh I did not know
you could do this with my hair it's the
eyebrows all right my grandma's all
about those dark eyebrows it just feels
like I've been through a lot that's what
it feels like for me it was a big deal
just moving across country but to know
that you're never gonna see your family
again kind of thing and no communication
whatsoever except for like a phone call
every now and then that's just oh my
gosh oh my gosh what I only know the
cultural things that she's passed down
to me so to be able to wear this and
have a connection to not only her but
also my grandmother who owned this it's
really nice because I don't always get
to share those things with her
Wow oh my gosh I'm so emotional right
now she's at the end of her life and I
wish I had appreciated her more it was
younger it's hard when you have that
like language barrier and you have the
cultural differences and knowing the
sacrifices that she made and all the
things she did for her family I just
wish I had understood that appreciated
that when I was younger being an
immigrant for some reason in this time
is something that is dividing us when
it's actually something that should be
uniting
and it took me a really really long time
for me to learn that being Asian and not
being from here was actually really cool
and it really informs how I go about my
life you can't let fear stop you from
moving forward and making a better life
for yourself no matter what the
situation you're in
you